sent researchers Fighting's doesn't
contribute to historical discoveries it
is often only a Pollock only a political
involved publishes and not a historical
our advert blue pros and J Alexander
Corman and yet sec wheels or represented
this trend the last convincing element
EG osmotic a classification is the for
polish ukrainian trend the previous
mentioned above trends have been
distinguished by means of scientific
criteria unlike the Polish Ukrainians a
trend which has been a defined using a
national key as a result people who
represent extreme views and extreme
metabolic all mythologies have been put
under the same category according to
josh motyka this trend represent lifter
polished of macau achieve its kiev
ganoush bc government draws and eager
haha guida to my mind a Polish history
of Polish Ukrainian relations can be
described using a perspective key the
first group consists of history on
representing the view that to understand
a phenomenal one has to look at it from
more than one and go perspective I call
them multi it multi-perspective
according to this role they need to
abandon the role of advocate of one side
such historians are trying to understand
but not necessarily accept the arguments
of both sides such attitude is
represented by revisionist occur
automatically searchers and some polish
Ukrainians I think Roman roast eager
ecology de and polish the dilution
agonies new knowledge they are they are
multi-perspective ians the second group
consists of researchers who approve of
one often national sometimes state
perspective I call them mano perspective
guns here come defenders of Polish
reasons
is a traditionalist and they caught part
of the Ukrainian side of the fence
organische in civil but the trend which
multi-car cause hace para scientific I
do not find as a part of historiography
was over they works can be treated as
neither scientific nor objective since
they shape a historical consciousness of
samples I have to refer to these
non-scientific course this trend
depicted the word seen from the only
through Andrew perspective in camas to
this trend among mentioned above Bruce
Carmen and future include polish
Ukrainians such Victor polished rock and
metal she is key the first three
represent national and auntie ukrainian
reviews interestingly that left wing
Democrat polish talk and polish
non-scientific outdoors use the same
jargon and reg identical conclusions
adopting header mono multi perspective
scientific approach or not historical
view defines the way how the Polish
Ukrainian conflict in the years nineteen
thirty-nine forty eight is described
alas let's have a look at it analyzing
the historical approach to selected
sensitive problems for problems the
first one Genesis duration and number of
casualties of own Obama's mother the
second anti-polish action of OPA ethnic
cleaning on genocide because it's true
attitude to polish Ukrainian attempts to
reach agreement and 82 top with this
direction in multi-perspective approach
mass murder involving Nia and ganesha
were consequences of seconds of numerous
events the long-term reasons reasons for
this are
contradiction of territorial interests a
recognition by part of Ukrainian as
society that the Second Republic of
Poland is an occupant of Ukraine
liquidation of Ukraine's cooling system
and pacification of Ukrainian villages
in second third path radicals of some
Ukrainian society Excel and accepting
terrorism as a way of political start a
struggle for objective reasons they are
talking about overpopulation and
civilization setback of those
territories the short-term reason is the
policy of socket and German occupants
Soviet deportations in the years 1940-41
so that it is possible to solve problems
by removing the whole social groups the
Holocaust of Jews was